I am pleased to announce an investment of almost $1 million to Tina
Safe Haven,
a 24 hour drop in center run by Nadine Away for youth aged 13 to 24.
This funding will support operations
and programming at Tina Safe Haven,
including counseling, support program, mentors,
resources and healthcare from an indigenous lead perspective
with a focus on relationship building.
What I am excited about is Manitoba
investing over $20 million into creating that change.
Tina's death brought forward so much for us,
but it shouldn't have happened.
We should not have had to lose her in order for systems to move
to protect and take care of.
Her family gifted us the name Tina's Safe Haven.
And I think for, for me,
that was a, a reminder that our,
our lovely young woman, even in death,
the power of her voice and the need for ongoing change.